autres... d DR souhaite Denis
Coderre 60 tous ça voici les
deux pas de ces débats.
♪ ♪ ♪
Du haut de ses 232 mètres
d'altitude, le mont Royal domine
la métropole depuis presque
400 ans. Mais peut-être plus
pour très longtemps.
L'ex-maire Denis Coderre, qui
tente un retour en politique,
aimerait permettre l'érection
de tours encore plus hautes que
la montagne, ce qui est interdit
depuis l'adoption du premier
plan d'urbanisme de la Ville
de Montréal, en 1992.
DENIS CODERRE, chef, Ensemble
Montréal, candidat, mairie MTL
- On va protéger le mont Royal
comme il a toujours été fait,
comme je l'ai fait à l'époque,
de toute façon. Mais la densité,
c'est sérieux. Il faut sortir
du dogmatisme continu, il faut
arrêter d'avoir des phrases
toutes faites, puis il faut
avoir un vrai débat sur l'enjeu.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le centre-ville compte
actuellement deux gratte-ciels
de 200 mètres : le 1000 de
la Gauchetière, officiellement
la plus grande tour de Montréal,
et le 1250 René-Lévesque.
C'est au pied de cet édifice que
nous attend Jean-Marc-Fournier.
Cet ancien ministre défend
aujourd'hui les intérêts des
promoteurs, qui plaident eux
aussi pour une densification
accrue.
EAN-MARC FOURNIER, pdg, Institut
développement urbain du Québec
- D'abord, il faut savoir quelle
est la problématique de Montréal
que tout le monde reconnaît :
l'offre en logements qui n'est
pas suffisante; l'abordabilité,
qui doit être améliorée; et
conséquemment, si on veut créer
des milieux de vie où il y a
aussi des pistes cyclables,
des voies piétonnes, des parcs,
il n'y a pas d'autres choix que
de construire en hauteur.
- Car malgré la pandémie,
la population du Grand Montréal
continue de croître sous
la pression de l'immigration
et des naissances : elle a déjà
franchi le cap des 4 millions
d'habitants, et devrait dépasser
les 4,5 millions d'habitants
d'ici 2036.
- Il y a un étalement urbain qui
se poursuit, on ne peut pas le
nier... Mais, les changements
climatiques vont commander qu'en
plus du discours, il y ait des
vraies actions. Ça veut dire,
entre autres, offrir une
densification heureuse.
- La proposition de Denis
Coderre a fait débat au
printemps, lors de la sortie
de son livre "Retrouver
Montréal".
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Nous sommes en désaccord
avec toute tentative d'obstruer
la vue du Mont-Royal au profit
d'un développement privé qui
ferait de Montréal une ville
comme n'importe quelle autre.
- La mairesse Plante a fait
adopter une motion par
le conseil municipal afin de
souligner l'importance
de préserver l'unicité du
paysage montréalais. Depuis,
son avis n'a pas trop changé.
- Il y a plein de façon de
densifier et j'ai envie de vous
dire qu'il faut sortir de
l'ancien modèle, qui, pour moi,
il date d'il y a 20, 30 ans, où
l'on se disait : "Densifier,
c'est en hauteur". On n'est plus
là! Alors, si on veut densifier
différemment, ça veut dire que
c'est le nombre de logements
qu'on met à l'intérieur,
le nombre de pieds carrés.
- La suggestion de Denis Coderre
lui a même fait perdre une élue
dans Verdun.
VÉRONIQUE TREMBLAY, cand. Projet
MTL Champlain- L'Île-des-Soeurs
- Je pense que la vision de
M. Coderre de construire en
hauteur extrême ne fait pas de
Montréal une plus grande
métropole ou une métropole
à niveau supérieur.
- Mais le scepticisme ne vient
pas que du milieu politique.
- Dans le fond, les gros
édifices vont bloquer la vue,
à quelque part.
- Ici, je trouve que c'est quand
même déjà très concentré. Alors,
d'en rajouter encore, après,
je pense que même pour la vue,
entre chaque bâtiment, ce sera
très compliqué. Enfin...
il n'y aura plus de paysages.
- Des organismes ont publié une
lettre ouverte en avril pour
réitérer l'importance de
la préservation et de la mise
en valeur du mont Royal.
SYLVAIN GARIÉPY, président
Ordre des urbanistes du Québec
- Peu de villes au monde peuvent
se targuer d'avoir une montagne
en arrière-scène qui fait partie
de son identité.
MARYLINE CHARBONNEAU, dir. aff.
publ. Les amis de la montagne
- Pourquoi qu'on voudrait cacher
quelque chose, justement, qui
fait la renommée de Montréal
et qui rend Montréal et
la métropole attractives?
- Quand j'ai parlé du Mont-
Royal, je voulais, évidemment,
provoquer le débat.
- Malgré ces critiques, Denis
Coderre entend garder le cap sur
sa proposition et l'inclure dans
la plateforme électorale de
son parti, Ensemble Montréal.
Mais il ne propose pas seulement
de densifier le centre-ville :
le candidat à la mairie
souhaiterait aussi revoir
les hauteurs permises dans
le secteur de l'ancien
hippodrome, sur le site
du projet Royalmount, près
des gares du Train de l'Est
et ailleurs dans la métropole,
là où les limites sont encore
plus basses que le mont Royal.
- Il faut être fédérateur,
arrêter de voir
les développeurs,
les responsables économiques,
comme des gens à qui on ne peut
pas parler, puis pointer
du doigt. On doit avoir un débat
sain sur la densité, et c'est
tout simplement ça. Maintenant,
il y a des gens qui peuvent
se satisfaire de peu.
- Le secteur des Faubourgs, près
du pont Jacques-Cartier, fait
partie des secteurs où un débat
fait rage sur les hauteurs
permises.
Et la question a refait surface,
en juillet, lorsque l'Office
de consultation publique a jugé
que la tour de verre du projet
immobilier La Baie était trop
haute.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est que l'appétit des
promoteurs immobiliers est
énorme. Au centre-ville, une
quinzaine de tours de plus de
120 mètres sont en construction;
cinq d'entre elles devraient
avoisiner les 200 mètres.
Pour l'instant, il demeure
toutefois interdit de construire
au-delà du mont Royal;
un privilège réservé à
l'Oratoire Saint-Joseph,
l'exception qui confirme
la règle, à 260 mètres au-dessus
du niveau de la mer.
Ici Jérôme Labbé,
Radio-Canada, M